WHOLE LOT WORSE.
JIM SCIUTTO IN UKRAINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH RETIRED GENERAL DAVID
PETRAEUS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
AS YOU KNOW, THE U.S. NOW
BELIEVES WHAT 8% TO 10% OF
RUSSIAN MILITARY ASSETS HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED IN LESS THAN TWO
WEEKS OF FIGHTING.
CAN THEY SUSTAIN THAT RATE OF
LOSS FOR SEVERAL MORE WEEKS OR
EVEN MONTHS?
>> WELL, IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
I VERY MUCH AGREE WITH JIM'S
ASSESSMENT.
A GRINDING AFFAIR.
ALSO, THE ASSESSMENT BY RETIRED
GENERAL ANDERSON THAT AGAIN, IT
IS A RACE TAKEN WITH OUR EARTH
TO SUPPLY THE UKRAINIANS AND THE
RUSSIAN EFFORTS TO RESUPPLY
THEIR FORCES.
THEIR LOGISTICS HAVE BEEN
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE SO FAR AND
TO LAUNCH WHAT THEY BELIEVE WILL
BE THE MAIN EFFORT ATTACK ON
KYIV.
OF COURSE, THEY WANT TO REPLACE
THE ZELENSKYY GOVERNMENT WITH
ONE THAT IS PRO RUSSIAN.
THAT'S THE OVERRIDING OBJECTIVE.
IT IS ALSO A RACE, I THINK,
WOLF, TO SEE HOW LONG THE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS CAN MAINTAIN
THE INTENSITY.
THEY'RE ABOUT TO ENTER THE MOST
DIFFICULT OF ALL COMBAT.
THAT IS URBAN COMBAT.
WE USED TO DISCUSS HOW LONG CAN
YOU KEEP SOLDIERS DOING THIS?
HOW MANY MORE BUILDINGS, HOW
MANY MORE ROOMS CAN A SOLDIER
ENTER?
EACH TIME THEY ENTER, THE
ADRENALINE IS PUMPING.
IT IS A VERY GRINDING, DRAINING
EXPERIENCE.
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT RUSSIA HAS
THE REPLACEMENTS.
YOU WILL RECALL IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN, WE REPLACED SOME OF
OUR FORCES EVERY SIX MONTHS.
OUR ARMY SOLDIERS WERE REPLACED
EVERY 12 MONTHS.
15 MONTHS DURING THE SURGE.
A LONG TIME IN COMBAT.
I'M NOT CONFIDENT THAT RUSSIA
CAN REPLACE THE FORCES THAT IT
IS LOSING, MUCH LESS THE ENTIRE
COME COMPLETE.
FORCES WHEN THEY'RE SPENT.
WHEN THEY COUPLE MINUTE IT A.
AND IT IS NOT JUST PHYSICAL.
IT IS GRINDING, YOU ARE BAN
COMBAT, BUT ALSO THE MENTAL TOLL
THAT IT TAKES, BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
WHEN YOU STRIP AWAY ALL THE
OTHER SYSTEMS, LOGISTICS AND
TANKS AND ARTILLERY, THIS REALLY
COME DOWN TO INFANTRY ON THE
GROUND WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
GO IN AFTER RUSSIA HAS PUMMELED,
IN SOME CASES, RUBBLED, AREAS OF
THE CITY AND CLEAR THOSE.
IN THE MENTAL TIME, ON THE OTHER
SIDE, YOU HAVE THE UKRAINIAN
DEFENDERS FIGHTING FOR THEIR
HOMELAND, DETERMINED NOT TO LET
RUSSIA TAKE THEIR CAPITAL.
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE A
TREMENDOUS SHOWDOWN.
AND I'M NOT, I'M NOT CONVINCED
THAT RUSSIA CAN JUST CRUSH
UKRAINE THE WAY THAT MANY
OBSERVERS PERHAPS THOUGHT BEFORE
WE SAW HOW WOEFUL SOME ASPECTS
OF RUSSIAN TACTICS, LOGISTICS,
AND EVEN CAMPAIGN DESIGN HAVE
BEEN.
>> IT CERTAINLY HASN'T HAPPENED
YET.
THE CRAFT DIRECTOR, YOU HEARD
HER, SAYS, YOU'VE HEARD HIM SAY
PUTIN OVERESTIMATED HIS OWN
MILITARY CAPACITY WHILE
UNDERESTIMATING UKRAINIAN
RESISTANCE, AS WELL AS THE
INTERNATIONAL RESPONSE.
WHY DID PATH SO GRAVELY, BY ALL
ACCOUNTS, MISCALCULATE?
>> Reporter: I'M SURE A LOT OF
HIS ADVISER ARE VERY COWED, SBIM
DA
DATED BY HIM UFRL EVEN SAW THAT
WITH HIS SURREAL CONFERENCES HE
HAS.
LONG SPEECHES AND SO FORTH.
BEYOND THAT, THEY DID PREVAIL IN
A WAY IN SYRIA.
OF COURSE, THE WAY THEY
PREVAILED WAS THEY DESTROYED
ALEPPO.
IT WAS SYRIAN FORCES ON THE
GROUND.
NOT THE RUSSIAN FORCES.
THEY ARE DOING THE BOMBING
CAMPAIGN AND SPECIAL OPERATIONS.
THE NAME IS GRASNY.
NUMBER ONE, THE SHEER QUALITY,
INNOVATIVENESS, RESOURCEFULNESS.
NOT JUST THE UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS.
THE PARTISANS AND OTHER
RESISTANCE.
THIS IS EQUIVALENT OF THE FRENCH
IN WORLD WAR II WHO ARE FINDING
EVERY DIABOLICALLY CREATIVE WAY
TO MAKE LIFE DIFFICULT FOR THE
RUSSIANS.
JAM GO THEIR FREQUENCIES,
CHANGING ROAD SIGNS, OR ACTUALLY
PICKING OFF THE FUEL TRUCKS.
IN 40-MILE CONVOY TO EXACERBATE
THE LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES THAT
RUSSIA IS ALREADY EXPERIENCING.
SO THIS IS GOING TO BE A
TREMENDOUS SHOWDOWN IN KYIV.
AND AGAIN, I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG
THE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS CAN KEEP AT
THIS.
IF YOU THINK OF THE LOSSES,
THEIR APPROACHING, THE VERY HIGH
ESTIMATE THERE, IS STARTING TO
APPROACH WHAT WE LOST IN 20
YEARS OF COMBAT IN IRAQ.
AND I REMEMBER HOW DIFFICULT
SOME OF THOSE WEEKS AND MONTHS
WERE.
I CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT THE STRAIN
MUST BE ON THE TACTICAL LEVEL.
COMMANDERS, THOSE ABOVE THEM.
AND OF COURSE, THEY'VE EVEN LOST
SOME MULTISTAR GENERALS.
ANOTHER ONE OF THEM JUST IN
RECENT 24 HOURS OR SO.
>> YEAH.
IT'S NOT GOING W